sobre balsas ilegales como esta maniobra
das por contrabandistas cientos de
migrantes centroamericanos intentan
cruzar el río grande buscan llegar a
suelo estadounidense en el tramo
conocido como romá en texas
los que tienen suerte lo logran pero los
que no se entregan a las autoridades
como ellos que agotados y con sus
pequeños a cuestas se dieron al hambre y
el frío tras rendirse son trasladados a
refugios como éste en donde elmer
maldonado un solicitante de asilo
hondureño de 40 años recuerda cómo
intentó atravesar la frontera con su
hijo isaac el motivo
y
y gas y cosas él viene bien motivado
cuando mira cositas bonitas de día y
desde cuando escucharon ruidos tan
fuerte le da miedito solo en la última
jornada al menos 30 hondureños como
elmer fueron guiados por un alguacil
para entregarse a la patrulla fronteriza
pero la situación más crítica la
afrontan los menores no acompañados a
medida que siguen pasando desde méjico
los centros de atención empiezan a
llegar a su capacidad máxima en medio de
esta crisis que la administración de
darden le achaca al pasado gobierno
el presidente trump se paró más de 3000
niños de sus padres y en 2019 tuvimos el
mayor aumento en décadas así que hay
muchas razones por la que los niños
deciden migrar estamos enviando un
mensaje muy claro la gente debe quedarse
en sus regiones
mientras localizan a sus familias a
algunos de los jóvenes que permanecen en
este albergue de carrizos prince
intentan refugiarse en el fútbol y así
olvidar por momentos la violencia y la
pobreza que los llevó a mirar